Moving on to transforming objects, we can use the translate, rotate, scale tools on
the viewport to move objects around the scene which I briefly spoke about in the viewport
overview.
You can toggle between world and local transforms as well.
So that is actually the little widget that's just here around my mouse next to the location,
rotation and scale widgets.
And then you can also use the details panel to enter transform values as we saw on the
options in the details panel, sorry, in the editor overview.
So you can just transform those values either through the widget or you can type in specific
values with each of the actors that you have selected.
So to give you a little bit idea about the viewport menu, so you can find these menus
at the top left of your viewport that we went over before, you'll see these four sections
here and each one contains a whole host of different settings that you may want to use
just to touch upon a few briefly.
Real time, generally you would have this enabled most of the time unless you didn't want the
scene in real time for some reason, maybe your computer can't support it or maybe you
just don't want to view the scene in real time.
So the good thing about all these settings is anything that you use frequently, they
have little hotkey shortcuts next to each property.
So if you want to learn a few of them for things that you use quite frequently, that's
a good practice to get into.
But yeah, essentially we can just show a few different options here, you know, allow cinematic
control, do you want to show the toolbar, different properties that just create your
editing experience, make your editing experience a bit more user friendly.
In the perspective tab, generally we're working a lot of time in perspective, but if you want
orthographic viewports, for example, you can select through the different orthographic
viewports there and you can also have a viewport layout that can house all four orthographic
viewports, for example, if you wanted the three orthographic viewports plus a perspective.
If there are any cameras in your map, you'll be able to select your cameras from here.
I generally don't use this setting too often, I generally go and locate the camera in the
scene, but it's also worthwhile just to know that these cameras are placed here as well.
And then depending on if you want a default viewport or a cinematic viewport, majority
of people will be using a default viewport.
However, a cinematic viewport gives you some nice cinematic controls, it gives you some
nice overlay masks, it gives you a third grid for your window if you're wanting to work
on cinematic.
So definitely worth toggling on and playing around if you're making cinematics.
And then on the next button across, you've got the different view modes and render modes
and they have loads of different view modes that help with visualization of the buffer,
Nanae, optimization view modes.
If you're trying to get your project to a more optimized approach, you can toggle through
the different view modes here.
A lot of really useful things.
And it's worth noting that you can toggle a lot of these view modes using console commands,
which are opened by pressing the tilde key on your keyboard, which is more often than
not next to the number one key on your keyboard.
So much depth and complexity to the different view modes that are available inside of Unreal
Engine.
And if you're interested in any of those, it's definitely worth following up on the
documentation of those.
And then you've got some exposure settings if you want to override any exposure and then
your color management.
On the show tab next, this is just per editor viewport what you want to be displaying inside
your scene.
So if you want to hide certain elements or features, it might be worth toggling some
of these options.
A nice little hotkey that isn't displayed here, I think is by pressing the T key, it
toggles transparency.
So if you have a lot of transparent surfaces in your scene, maybe you have a lot of windows
or god rays that are static meshes coming through, maybe there's just some kind of transparency
going on, which you just keep selecting the transparent objects instead of the actual
object you're trying to select.
You can hit the T key to toggle between transparency modes, which I find quite useful a lot of the time.